BRETT MORGAN: Hello.
I'm Brett Morgan from the
Google Maps Developer
Relations Team.
This week, I'd like to show you
how to integrate Street
View imagery into your
application using the latest
version of the Google
Maps SDK for iOS.
Google has captured street-level
panorama images
of more than 5 million miles
of road and continues to
update this imagery as
the world changes.
Integrating Street View into
your application allows you to
give users context from the real
world that matches your
application.
For example, let's say you're
making an application that
brings people together.
Wouldn't it be nice to be able
to show people the pub that
they're going to meet at?
Or let's say you're making a
real estate sales application.
Wouldn't it be nice to show
people their new front yard?
All of Street View panoramas
are captures as 360 degree
images and are shown
in your application
using a special viewer.
Let me show you how.
The viewer on iOS is represented
by the GMS
panorama view class, similar
to a JMS map view class.
I've created a new UI view
controller, and I'll add the
JMS panorama view object that
will fill the whole screen.
Once you've added the
viewer, you next
need to load an image.
In this case, I'll load an image
near the coordinate that
I know has a good view of the
Sydney Harbor Bridge.
Let's take a look at
what we have now.
The viewer allows your user
to zoom and pan the image.
Ah, there's the bridge.
You can also programmatically
control the
orientation of the camera.
Let's change the code a bit so
that we start the picture of
the bridge.
There we go.
That's a whole lot better.
Now when users launch the app,
they will see exactly the
right view.
If you want to control
what the user of
your application sees--
for example, if you're
presenting a slide show of
properties for sale-- you can
disable user-interactive
gestures by calling set all
gestures enabled no on your
JMS panorama view object.
Setting the navigation links
hidden and street names hidden
to yes will enhance the slide
view aspect of your
application by hiding street
labels and navigation arrows,
leaving you with just the
wonderful houses for sale.
Thank you for watching this
week's GDL on integrating
Street View into your
iOS applications.
If you have any questions on the
techniques presented here
this week, please reach out to
us on either Google+ or on
Stack Overflow using the Google
Maps SDK iOS tag.
Thank you for watching.